Taylor swiv gossip she's done a genius
thing she appeals to Children there so
many female pop stars it's all about
being hypersexualized I can't let my kid
listen to this she's done this genius
thing have you seen her dancing I think
she's very mindful about not being too
overtly sexual it's not sexy it's like
awkward there's never any sexuality
about it there's never any singing about
sex it's always just like getting your
heartbroken in these kind of relatively
like Teenage feelings she did this one
thing where she got called a snake there
was like all these snake emojis either
someone cheated on someone and someone
asked her in an interview they said so
what do you feel about the fact that so
many people online call you a snake and
she went snakes eat rats that's pretty
gangster like I see why girls like look
up to her every time people come for her
she manages to sublimate it into
something else